go long wait stop don't limit my route  kirk i mean josh we must never go there  that's  the new york section of gridiron heights  year and a half almost patient run yet  all right i guess i'll go into super  bowl then  let's get the ball back we need to prove  we can get a big win here free comedy  free comedy come just watch the jets be  the jets hot dogs i gotta get rid of  these glory hogs they have no place on a  real name okay  hey i'm vlogging here uncle frank back  when i started times square still had  that big toys r us  hey don't you owe me something yes judge  one  two look i'm like brabel if you follow  the safety guidelines  judge i've got my bug eyes on you this  is jets territory we can bust out of  this god forsaken town  together we can net a third round pick  oh sorry he's all  get out now while you can still back up  for an aging vet oh  damn you nyc technically we play in  jersey  thank goodness we're home safe  [Music]  i'm just so happy